Pedro Gonzalez is the associator of
Chronicles magazine he joins us tonight
Pedro what do you make of this
well Tucker thanks for having me well uh
the system that failed and resulted in
the FDA grounding uh the FAA grounding
all those flights is actually 30 years
old and it's not due for an update for
another six years and I was actually
trapped at an airport yesterday for
several hours and ultimately it's
probably going to take me longer to get
back to my family but when I was uh
thinking about this clearly I was filled
with a warm and fuzzy feeling because
our transportations are is married to a
man and believes roads are racist so all
of this is actually progress except it's
not change is not the same thing as
progress obviously we're witnessing the
Third World vacation of U.S
infrastructure and mayor Pete is
actually the ideal guy to oversee this
decline he has all of the right
credentials under the rubric of
liberalism I think that's important
people say he's not qualified he
actually is he has all of these
important but ultimately meaningless
credentials stapled to his goofy
forehead and he can claim uh status with
a sacred victim group Pete butterjudge
does not ask questions when the
government wants to ban your gas stove
to fight climate change and when it
can't put airplanes safely in the sky he
also has all the right bromides at hand
in other words he's ready to say a whole
lot of nothing
it's just weird that people put up this
I mean it's one thing you've got all
your like freaky theories about sex
changes or whatever but ultimately you
kind of have to make sure the planes
don't crash that they can take off in
the first place the power grid Works
people should not put up with a
degradation in the basics why are they
I think because we've gotten used to
this it seems like inertia and it's not
just happening on the level of
government I mean remember think back to
the summer of Saint George Floyd uh
Citigroup one of the sleaziest
organizations one of the sleaziest
financial institutions in this in the
world uh rehabilitate itself it
rebranded itself not by changing
structurally like you said you would
expect an organization like that to
change structurally instead City just
came out Against Racism and then
suddenly people stopped demanding change
and they settled for wealth City opposes
racism and that's good enough for me
that is so true that I'm chuckling at it
you're absolutely right Pedro Gonzalez
great to see you tonight thank you
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight